foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today or tonight depending on where
you're from for our live broadcast and
today we can finally shout it from the
mountaintops it is World thrombosis day
we're super excited about
um we have a very special guest today
which I'm really excited to announce and
introduce and we have another guest
returning to
um our live so um let me just get
started I'm your host Dr Arielle dance
um in addition to hosting our world
thrombosis day Facebook lives I'm also a
multiple blood clot Survivor um in my
20s many times and so I'm super excited
to still be alive and this is the day
that we celebrate still being here so
super grateful for that
um as I mentioned earlier today's a
special day not just for us because it's
World thrombosis day but because we are
joined by an extremely special guest
YouTube star and US World thrombosis day
Patient Advocate Justine ezarik so I'm
super excited hi Justine so excited
hello thanks so much for having me I
Justine I think that some people may be
here and only know you by that name so I
feel like we should go go either way so
just I'm just going to read like your
little bio is that okay unless you want
to like go for it yourself I'll do okay
I'll do it you got this
Christine is one of the top female Tech
personalities on YouTube right now with
over 1 billion views and seven million
followers and Justine start on the
YouTube comedy series Annoying Orange
um on and in 2016 she was an advisor to
Arnold Schwarzenegger on the reality
competition series the new Celebrity
Apprentice
um her television acting credits include
guest appearances on Law and Order SVU
special Victims Unit
um The Bold and the Beautiful and The
Vampire Diaries which we've all been
geeking out about on the team Justine
also appeared as the main character of
the YouTube Premiere murder mystery
reality series escape the night so
Justine welcome to this year's World
thrombosis live we are so excited to
have you and would you like to say a few
words before we really get started
yeah I mean I'm so excited to be a part
of this but also when you think about it
I'm like look this is the craziest
things earlier this year I would have
never even known what world thrombosis
day is so it's kind of unfortunate but
also fortunate that I am in this
position to be able to share my story
with my viewers and with people outside
of that and kind of connect with other
people who have been through the same
thing and even a part of my healing
Journey was connecting with other people
who have had this or who have had
something similar and able to share
experiences and get suggestions on
healing so I'm just super grateful to be
here I'm grateful for my audience that
they have been so supportive I can see
all of their comments coming in so thank
you guys all for coming to hang out with
us
this is so awesome and I can't wait to
talk a little bit more about your
journey and your experiences
um I watched you know a few of your
YouTube videos specifically about your
health journey and I was like oh yeah me
too oh yeah that was me too so I can't
wait to talk a little bit more but I
cannot do it without acknowledging that
we have Dr Gene Connors here with us
today but Dr Connors allowed me to just
call her Jean so we will go by Jean
um so we have Gene here with us who is
the medical director of anticoagulation
services at Brigham and Women's Hospital
and Dana Farber Cancer Institute in
Boston Massachusetts in the U.S and an
associate professor of medicine at
Harvard she is also a member of the
world thrombosis day steering committee
um so super excited to have you here
Gene and I want to also give you a
chance if you wanted to say hello and
welcome well hello and and I'm delighted
to be invited back this year again
um to to pair with you uh Arielle as a
great patient advocate advocate for
World thrombosis day and bring along
um Justine I think both of you have very
compelling stories to tell and and I
think it's great that we're bringing
this uh public awareness campaign and
letting people really know that that
clots happen and they can happen to not
just you know the older patients sitting
in the hospital but to Young active very
healthy patients so thank you for for
inviting me today and thanks to the
audience for helping us celebrate World
thrombosis day yes so excited and then I
feel like we should maybe explain what
world thrombosis day is or at least what
a thrombosis is
um so I'll just give a little background
so today is World thrombosis day happens
every October 13th and we're placing a
Global Spotlight on thrombosis also
known as blood clots it's an urgent and
growing health problem so we know that
one in four people globally are dying
from this condition relate any
conditions related to blood clots and so
World thrombosis day campaign raises
that awareness empowers patients
provides recovery resources and works
with Healthcare Professionals in more
than 125 countries to educate their
communities about the signs symptoms and
risk factors so
World thrombosis day as I said is taking
place on October 13th for a specific
reason it is the birthday of Rudolph
verkau who is a German scientist who
developed the concept of thrombosis so
today is his 201st birthday happy
birthday Rudolph super happy for you and
thank you
and Jean's really good at kind of
explaining a little bit more about all
of the the goodies about like how we
know thrombosis works so if you want to
get into that we'll talk about in a
minute but also in addition to
celebrating virkau's birthday today
World thrombosis day is the day to
recognize and strengthen our resilience
of um as survivors of blood clots around
the world and so the experience of
having a blood clot can be so difficult
physically on the body which you know
Justine you're going to talk about that
but also emotionally and mentally and I
hope we get to touch on that as well
um and so we want to recognize all of
our survivors if you're here please drop
you know who you are in the chat where
you're tuning in from because we love to
celebrate the fact that you're still
with us and you're still alive so um
because today is World thrombosis day
we're excited to have both iJustine and
Dr Connors with us Plus
we are giving away two fifty dollar
Apple gift cards during the broadcast in
the comment section and we'll also give
out some T-shirts following the live so
please pay attention to the clues put
your name be interactive in the chat so
you can get all the goodies today and we
invite you to be as active and involved
ask all the questions and we hope that
we get to as many as possible all right
that was housekeeping let's get started
so I'm going to start with you Justine
again thank you for being here with us
but
um
earlier
in the year you shared that your you
shared your blood clot stories with
millions of You YouTube followers
um can you tell us a little bit about
like what happened and how your viewers
have helped support you through your
journey
yeah so it was actually April 1st
so I was hoping that that was you know
like an April Fool's joke my body was
playing on me but unfortunately it was
not but earlier in that week I was at an
event and it was weird because I felt
like super tired like a tiredness that
I'd never felt before so my first
thought was like oh I probably have
covered so I took kova tests all that
week because I didn't want to go to this
event if I was if I was contagious or
something so I kept coming up negative
negative negative I'm like okay well
that's weird maybe I'm just tired from
interacting with people or maybe I'm
tired from my workouts and then my arms
started feeling weird and I texted my
sister and sometimes I can be a little
bit dramatic
um so when I told my sister I had a
blood clot she was like
you know slightly concerned but she's
like well you know if something happens
like I'll take you to the ER and instead
I took a shower it felt like the
swelling went down and I continued on my
day I went to dinner went to events and
then it was that Friday so maybe like
two three days later it just it felt
like it was getting worse actually it
was Thursday night because then Friday
was when I went actually to the hospital
and I woke up that morning and I was
like something is definitely wrong like
I got up at 5am we were supposed to go
do this a podcast and so I went packed
all the gear and I was like I can't even
bend my arm to dry my hair and
it was just such a surreal experience
because it was like a part of my body
was like not functioning the way that it
should and there wasn't a lot of pain so
normally I feel like you associate pain
with something being wrong so I kept
thinking well this doesn't hurt so I
must be okay but then when I started
seeing like the blood vessels start
breaking in my shoulder I was like okay
this is this is not right and then my
arms started turned purple and so I went
to the
like an urgent care and when I showed
the woman my arm I was like I think I
might have a blood clot she could look
to me she's like
we're not equipped for this you got to
go to the emergency room so she started
freaking out and then I was like hmm
okay if she's freaking out I should
start freaking out for some reason I
didn't really freak out I just told my
sister I was like we gotta go to the ER
so we went I went in you know basically
told them I think I have a blood clot
they looked at it and you know they got
me admitted pretty quickly and did the
ultrasound to confirm that you know
there was a clot
got me on the blood thinners and then
said I needed to go to another hospital
that was more equipped to do the um
what's it I don't want to pronounce it
wrong because I know there was like the
thrombectomy which is
which they kind of like poke it out and
then there's like the throm what's the
other one yeah so there's thrombectomy
where they go in with a catheter and
they actually pull the clot out and
extract it yeah and then there's uh
catheter directed thrombolysis where
they put a flexible catheter in the
vessel and they deliver through
continuous infusion for 12 24 hours
usually
um a drug that dissolves clots called
TPA
that's what I had
and it was actually it was super scary
especially because my sister's a
pharmacist and then when I called her
she ran me through all the risks you
know and and so then I'm like sitting
here
well actually laying in the the
operating room before they're ready to
do this procedure and the only thing
that I know are the risks so I'm
freaking out and then we actually have
another YouTuber friend who's uh uh a
radiologist also that does this
procedure so we literally had one of my
friends on speed dial who was also like
walking me through this so super
grateful to to have somebody who was you
know a close friend and also a doctor
that does this to be like look this is
what I normally would do and he's like
if I was you like if you were my patient
this is what I would do so that was
super helpful to kind of have you know
my sister and a friend to kind of walk
me through this because
you know I mean sometimes I think it's
really difficult for a lot of doctors
they don't really have that kind of
bedside manner to make you feel
comfortable and so I mean the doctors
were all great but I was like you're not
explaining to me like I'm a
five-year-old what what is happening and
that's what I need right now
yeah you know I just want to jump in for
a second and see that
um your ability to be so proactive for
yourself and your health and actually
recognize that you might have a blood
clot I think makes a huge impact and
difference because I've seen many cases
where people have had maybe not as
dramatic swelling but they have swelling
in their leg or or they have chest pain
and they go to the emergency room or
they go to an urgent care center and the
doctors or the nurse practitioners or
their physician assistants don't really
think that somebody your age could have
a blood clot so so you get a lot of
credit in my book for for recognizing
that you might have had a blood clot or
a blood clot might be forming and I
think that's very important yeah I mean
I think I'm very lucky too because my
mom is you know she's very health
conscious and knows a lot about the
medical field as well so like any time
we were growing up or any time we would
be going on flights she would always
make us wear compression socks and
always like warning us a blood clots so
like in the back of my mind
you know anytime I get off of a flight
I'm like do I have a blood clot so it's
like that has always been something
that's been green since I was very young
so the fact that I kind of had that
knowledge and already kind of just felt
like that's what it was I'm super
grateful because I think you know maybe
somebody I mean it was so purple that no
one would have been able to ignore me at
that point because it was not cool it
was like terrifying it was like I looked
like I had this massive bicep I was like
did I like go a little extra hard at the
gym I'm not sure like it was not it was
not normal so I definitely knew
something wasn't right
so you're actually bringing me to one of
my main questions for um Gene Gene how
common is it for
um blood clots to form in the arm you
know we talk a lot about blood clots in
the lungs automatically or I've heard in
the groin I've heard in the leg but the
arm seems to be less common I don't know
yeah no the arm's less common because it
has less effects of gravity quite
honestly compared to your legs when
you're standing up and so the clots that
tend to form there are either because
people might have an IV in or a long IV
or something called a central axis
catheter or people like Justine and I'll
let her describe you know what ended up
causing the clot lots of upper extremity
clots as we call them uh clots in your
arm the upper extremity
um happen to people who do a lot of
repetitive motion type of things like
sports or I've seen Carpenters who do a
lot of hammering over their head I had a
woman who was a bartender who had the
glasses were always above and she also
had a catheter but she kept reaching and
then her arms swelled up and not as
dramatically and again she had a clot in
her arm so we do see it commonly in
athletes as well a long distance
baseball players so long swimmers and
and baseball players and things like
that where
um sometimes it's the muscles that swell
up and compress the blood vessels
I have to say because you know this is
what I do for a living uh verkal
actually was responsible for for
identifying three components that result
in causing a blood clot something is
called stasis where the blood flow is
interrupted and it slows down a second
might be an underlying hyper-coagulable
state for some reason people may have an
easier ability to clot because of what's
in their blood and the third thing is
often trauma so people have various
components of those but long distance
swimmers and baseball pitchers who are
repetitively pitching their muscles can
sometimes swell and and compress the the
vein leading uh from you know bringing
the blood out of their arm into their
body Justine had a unique uh condition
as well that we see uh and that should
be suspected in people uh who have an
arm uh swelling and a clot in their arm
and also something that you know I I
found interesting in my research you can
kind of talk more about that but there's
like a few different types of thoracic
outlet syndrome there's like the artery
there's the vein and like there's
different in the nerves too so
um I met a woman who had the nerve
thoracic outlet syndrome and she
recommended me to one of her physical
therapists so I was doing physical
therapy for uh like maybe two or three
months and it seemed to kind of help
because it was sort of like opening up
the muscles and doing that kind of stuff
but the my physical therapist she's like
I want to be honest with you because
this is the vein type I want to be very
careful because with the vein you can
tell if you are getting better because
you can have that sense of pain where I
don't have that so she's like I'm a
little nervous to continue working on
you once you're off the blood thinners
because we won't have that extra kind of
barrier of protection and um but I was
just reading in some of the comments too
and Ray was asking if blood clots are
more common in females or is there kind
of any so it's kind of interesting
because
um you know if we started like age zero
or one and we go up to 60 women have a
little bit higher incidents of of having
blood clots occur in around age 30 and a
little bit on either side because of
pregnancy which is a very high risk a
very hyper-coagulable State taking
combination estrogen progesterone oral
contraceptives say the estrogen
component really increases your risk but
then as aging goes on men have a much
higher risk
everybody's risk really starts to
increase at age 60. and so you know when
when somebody's over the age of 60
people in emergency rooms tend to think
more of blood clots which is why I think
it's very important that both of you are
such great Patient Advocates to to bring
awareness to the fact that young people
can have clots
yeah I've talked to a bunch of other
like athletes so I met a tennis player
which she was actually even younger than
me and she had the same exact thing uh
like you said baseball players swimmers
like I've
it runs the gamut of people that I've
met because of this and sort of that
athletic kind of
um scenario too and for me personally
for anyone that doesn't know I
previously was doing a ton of martial
arts and also like sword training and
then we also kind of transitioned that
into lightsaber training so it was a ton
of just repetitive just you know
spinning a lightsaber and fighting so
you know I would do that maybe three
times a week and then kind of practice
on my own so it was a lot of that and I
mean I think that's really the only
thing that I can kind of say would have
a factor that would kind of play into
that
yeah and that's you know I think from
what I understand you've had what we
call thoracic outlet syndrome where one
of the ribs presses on that that bundle
of nerves
um or artery or vein that that runs
through that small space and the space
can be smaller from person to person and
so again I've seen um competitive rowers
that have this same problem uh and some
of them often need surgery to decompress
that area because the vein sometimes
gets scarred and that's a whole nother
story but yeah it's thoracic outlet
syndrome is is very common in young
people who engage in the types of sports
that you were doing Justine
yeah and you know they told me if I want
to kind of get back to doing those
things like I should have a rib removed
so even now I'm I've been super cautious
I haven't really been doing that as much
and even when I do like yoga or some
kind of like overhead lifts like I start
feeling a little weird so I start
getting nervous I'm like is this
happening again I don't know and so it
definitely is in my future plans to you
know assess and and get this rib removed
because I just feel like obviously this
is something that will help me in the
long run and obviously I would rather do
it now while I'm younger and not wait
until something you know happens but you
know I feel like I've already kind of
pushed my limit of how much time I
should wait because it really is scary
and I think it's something that I do
think about every single day and I just
got back from a long trip of traveling
so it's like that whole time when I was
traveling you know when you're on Long
flights like that that's also you know
that's high risk so I was it's something
that I think even a lot of other
survivors here can attest to that like
it doesn't leave you you you're always
thinking about it even if you feel good
you're just like what if you know you
just never know
so true Justine so true
so we have some really good questions
coming in
um we're going to do a giveaway why not
so um I'm gonna take a question from
Eric and from Louise and if you'd like
your T-shirt you should
private message the world thrombosis day
Facebook account Eric and Louise so
thank you so Eric's question is does a
person's diet have anything to do with
getting a blood clot I'll throw this to
Eugene
um and Eric is saying they've never had
a blood clot before so they're just
asking no it's a great question because
um that the short answer is no they're
really no diet
component to getting a venous blood clot
for different types of blood clots I
have to be honest like stroke and heart
attacks then we get into the whole
cholesterol type of impact in your diet
but the type of clots that both Ariel
and Justine had have nothing to do uh
with with diet
yeah and something else whenever I went
on the blood thinners it was like the
first thing that I thought was like oh
do I have to change my diet because of
this and like because there's various
types like sometimes yes you do but it
was just a whole kind of learning curve
and something else was kind of
interesting that came out of all of this
is for me the the pain that I felt
of caffeine withdrawal it was way worse
than the blood clot pain so since then
I've just kind of stayed off caffeine so
people think that I'm not allowed to to
drink it because of the blood clot and
that's that's not the case at all that
was merely a personal decision but I
feel like that has kind of helped me in
the long run because I do feel like when
I was drinking coffee I would always
feel anxious I would have heart
palpitations and it's like all of that
has gone away so that has helped me even
just sort of in an overall kind of sense
of my well-being
yeah no it it's um when I when people
have had a blood clot then as you both
have said in the Years some anxiety
about is it coming back is this new pain
related to a clot am I getting another
one and so the diet question comes up is
there anything I can do
um to prevent it in in that respect diet
is not one of the key components
um as Justine mentioned there is an
anticoagulant called warfarin where you
have to be very careful about the
vitamin K containing uh substances green
leafy vegetables in and stuff like that
thank you both so Louise's question is
uh Justine have you found that you as
you tell your story that people are
typically not aware of blood clots
um and have you also found that many
people have similar experiences
yeah I definitely have found kind of
both scenarios where people will either
say oh my gosh like I've
either had one or I've have a relative
or like an older relative or something
like that because it again you know it
does commonly affect older people so
when you hear these stories of younger
people with them it can be kind of
shocking and I think it's it's been
great to be able to educate and even
just kind of reading through the
comments after I posted stuff on like
Tick Tock and all of those kinds of
things I think there's still so many
misconceptions and you know like you
said uh talking about like birth control
because a lot of younger and younger
people are starting on birth control at
earlier ages and I think that's
something that like people need to be
aware of because I think a lot of people
don't know they just think oh I'm on
this and then everything's going to be
fine so I think that's something that's
been important for me to to kind of
alert people and I just for the record
like I was not on birth control I am not
so that was not a contributing factor
and I think there's a lot of other
things that people like to think that
they know why this happened like it has
been proven that this is purely
anatomical for me like my rib like I saw
what was happening like I have all of
the the CT scans like I can see the
blood I can see where my rib is and it's
pressing on that whenever I raise my arm
so I think there's a lot of things that
can cause blood clots but for mine
personally it was an anatomical and in
my medical records it says I I'm
basically a Jedi so I love that every
time the doctors would come in they're
like
so how are you feeling and we also need
to talk about something and I was like I
get scared I'm like what's wrong they go
lightsaber training what is that
records Jedi I love that it's funny that
you brought up the birth control you
know
um concept and how it can be you know
it's known people kind of know now I
think
um that birth control can have a link to
blood clots I was on birth control when
I had my blood clot but I also had
recently had surgery and I was also you
know found out I had like a genetic
mutation
a whole lot of things were happening but
um I think you do speak to kind of like
what do we know and what do we still
need to learn and but I love telling
people like the warning label on birth
control is real specifically to young
people because I'm like we have a lot of
us were on birth control in our teens
and we're taking it still into our 30s
and I'm like just letting you know like
just be careful because it happened to
me and it could happen to you and you
know you just I think sharing your story
it's really what does it so you know
even people just knowing that it's a
possibility for them and knowing the
risk factors knowing the warning signs
makes all the difference I've seen so
many lives saved just because they said
I think this is that thing Arielle was
talking about and then they went to the
doctor it was like oh I have it I have a
blood clot and it's like yeah I'm glad
you went to the doctor because I wasn't
just talking like you know out the side
of my neck it was like real scary stuff
happening so keep sharing your story
this is for everyone share your story
all the time you're going to save a life
I promise
and another thing too is knowing what's
normal for you because I have a pretty
low blood pressure and a pretty low
heart rate so when I was at the doctor
my sister was also there too so she was
just absolutely incredible I mean I
couldn't use either of my arms so she
was like feeding me like changing my
clothes like brushing my hair she even
brought some dry shampoo and gave me a
little hairdo the one day but she also
knows like I have a very low blood
pressure low heart rate so
I was having kind of like a weird kind
of I don't wasn't like a pain but I felt
something strange like it felt like like
I could actually feel like I felt the
clot like moving to my lungs like I
don't know if I was like making it up
but like something felt weird and then
at that time like I felt my heart kind
of
speeding up a little and I like looked
at the all of the machines that was
hooked up and I was like okay so my
heart rate's a little bit higher than
normal then they took my blood pressure
and they're like that's normal I go
that's not normal for me my sister goes
absolutely not that's that's high that
is high for her and so they then took me
down and and did a CT scan and then
found out the clot did end up traveling
to my lungs so it was like those things
that I was like am I crazy this is
normal but for you it's not so I think
just you know I think run into like your
local like Walgreens CVS whatever your
Pharmacy is and use one of their blood
pressure machines and just you know
every once in a while kind of figure out
like what your normal is for you because
what your normal might be for others it
might not be for you so I think that's
just one piece of advice I think that is
really important for a lot of people
I love that and that's so true I know
for you Justine you're really into
um like technology for your health
um so and I think that that helps a
little bit also with like knowing what
your Norm is because you know like we
have our Apple watches people have their
fitbits and we look and we can see our
heart rate so all day I'm I'm paying
attention to like what my Norm is
um so what are your current like Health
devices Health Technologies that you're
really um working with to like stay on
top of your health right now yeah
there's um it's it's called we things or
with things I always mispronounce it but
it's
w-i-t-h-i-n-g-s and they have like blood
pressure they have scales and they have
like a thermometer so those all connect
to my app so I can just do a little
temperature check I can do my blood
pressure it all sinks to my phone and
then of course I have the aura ring and
I've lost my airpod and so I've been
wearing the aura ring pretty much every
day since August now it is mostly a
sleep tracker but it does do consistent
body temperature it does blood oxygen
levels and it also does like heart rate
too so I have all of that data in
addition to like my Apple watch which I
pretty much wear all the time so it's
like my Apple watch has like eight or
nine years of data of from my heart so
it's like I have so much information and
you know just being able to to have that
is great but I think really even just
having a blood pressure cuff so that I'm
able to just if I start feeling a little
weird go test it if I'm feeling
perfectly fine test it so I can just at
least kind of know what that is but
those are kind of my main sort of Health
Tech things that I usually use
you know I think you speak to knowing
your Baseline right and and it is so
easy now with all the tech we have
um for people to to sort of get an idea
of what their Baseline is because I
think it's great there you were sitting
in the hospital and having a heart rate
monitor and seeing your heart rate go up
right because often those things get
missed and it's um and that you probably
did feel the symptoms it's very
interesting talking to people who've had
clots that have clearly migrated so
again knowing your Baseline and not
being afraid to bring up symptoms I
think is the biggest
um piece of advice uh to both of you are
saying you know go see Health Care
Providers if you have new symptoms or
something that doesn't seem right
because sometimes the symptoms can vary
from person to person so an arm or leg
can swell up it can turn purple it can
turn blue it can hurt it doesn't have to
hurt as you know your arm Justine but
but pulmonary embolisms can be a little
different and so I wonder entering um
Ariel what kind of symptoms you had with
your pulmonary emboli because see
they're not always the same and I can
tell you I've heard a lot of different
stories where when they were first told
to people people didn't even pulmonary
embolus was not the first thing that the
doctors thought of
yeah so I thought I was having an asthma
attack and then I also thought I had gas
so like it was like a gas bubble in my
back so I was taking
um like medicine for that and then I was
taking my inhaler but I couldn't lay
back I couldn't sit back in a chair I
couldn't do anything it was just like
sharp pain between my back and then the
shortness of breath and so um yeah those
are my primary symptoms but then I heard
justines and she was like yeah I just
kind of feel like pain and then I was
like they didn't even put her have to
put her on Like Oxygen like I was like
the 25 year old with an oxygen tank like
I was like you're so lucky I was like
but that was my primary thing like I was
just clots Galore so
um yeah that's kind of like breathing
back pain is not what people usually
think of when you guys people say chest
pain and not back pain right and so the
shortness of breath if you have asthma
or if you have other breed you know
people think they have a cold or because
they have a cough but nothing's coming
up when they cough and and cough alone
can sometimes be a sign of pulmonary
embolus so not to worry people uh but to
be aware and if something doesn't seem
right that a blood clot is possible
it's also interesting because like I
thought I had asthma for like the past
couple of years I would just get a weird
cough so I'm wondering if like I haven't
kind of had this chronically if maybe
some of them have just been kind of
cruising through and thankfully making
their way because it would be so weird
I'm like I don't really have asthma I
don't know why I have this weird cough
like it it wasn't making sense so that
whenever I found out that that was also
something I was like have I been having
this for a while and I didn't even know
and I've just been very lucky is that a
possibility
yeah well so so I one thing that that
that it absolutely is a possibility that
that people have clots and they're not
um compromised that's the buzzword we
use
um so so they still get enough oxygen
their heart rate doesn't go up enough
they're not dizzy or lightheaded
um but sometimes they can have a clot
and we pick those up on CT scans when
they're done for some other reason or
um in your case it you know the CT scan
that was done should have picked up any
old clots versus new clots and what I
often do uh my dog's acting up
um what I often do is once I've decided
someone's had enough anticoagulation I
will get a repeat scan if we're going to
stop so that we know what the new
Baseline looks like in case because
sometimes clots can persist
um and we call them more scar type clots
um but but it is possible that you had
small ones and they dissolve down their
own
yeah it's super scary because you really
don't know and it was weird because like
I felt
it felt like the the coffee anxiety
feeling that I would get like when I was
drinking coffee so like that's kind of
what it felt like and so it was I was
like I'm not on caffeine so like that's
not it I just sort of felt it's like you
felt the anxiety feeling but I was like
I'm not feeling anxious it was like like
I could just feel it kind of traveling
it was so weird and it was just like I
told my sister I was like I really think
something's wrong she's like well we
gotta tell somebody so I did and it was
weird because it's like this whole
time that I was in the hospital like
I don't know how to explain it it was
kind of like I was just like completely
blacked out but yet I was like super
Pleasant and like
being friends with everybody and just
trying to make I guess the doctor's
experience like when they came in like
fun so that I don't know it was just
like
it's a weird thing because it's like you
want to be treating the doctors as nice
as possible too because like they have
your life in their hands and it's like
it's such a weird thing because it's
like I I want to have that connection
with these people so it's like I want
them to talk to me I want to be able to
talk to them so I don't know I'm just so
grateful for the incredible care that I
had that I was like I just want to be so
appreciative I just I wanted to hug
everybody because I was like you guys
are literally saving my life and like I
couldn't be just more grateful to to be
in such great care
we're happy to hear that shout out yeah
now if you if you have great care please
tell your providers uh that you really
appreciate them
um so yeah no there's a there's a lot of
you know in the moment symptoms with
pulmonary embolism when people are first
diagnosed it can be overwhelming uh and
then as it sort of settles in it comes
up the question of well what caused this
uh sometimes we never figure that out so
it's great that both of you seem to have
an idea you know Ariel the surgery and
Justine the lightsaber Jedi uh level of
training
um you know but I I can imagine that
many people aren't aware
um and in some cases we can't figure out
what caused it
I want to go back a little bit
um Justine you started using words like
anxiety and fear and then gratitude and
appreciation and so I wanted to kind of
transition us into the um not so
physical side of this experience for you
um you know we recently had a live
specifically talking about our
caregivers and the importance of having
a support system
um and uh and someone said that your
sister may actually be here and you
brought up your sister a few times so
she may be watching so hi sister hello
thank you so much for all you did for
Justine she's really grateful so I hear
her
um but can you tell us a little bit
about like what that experience was like
for you either the emotional side of it
um or either how it's been
um or if you just want to talk about
like what your support system has been
like
yeah I mean my family has been super
supportive they may be watching because
they're actually downstairs right now so
I was like you guys have to be quiet I
want to live stream and our little niece
Brynn she's three and she's wild so
she's probably tearing the house apart
um but yeah my family's been super
supportive and my sister you know we
live pretty close to each other so she
was I mean she basically was like
looking on me Non-Stop and just you know
definitely everyone has been super
supportive but I think the recovery
process was so crazy just to go from it
was insane because I felt like I was in
such good shape I was like running I was
doing all my weight lifting and I
finally like got back to like where I
felt great and then I was like this
doesn't make any sense like how did this
happen and then I basically couldn't
even work out for like a month and then
I was just like feeling depressed I was
feeling sad and like I was supposed to
go on a trip to Hawaii that week so then
you know everyone went without me and I
was just like
because I couldn't travel so it was it
was just tough from you know going to
basically living a sedentary lifestyle
for a month not being able to do my
martial arts not being able to do
um you know not be able to run and it
was like all of the kind of coping
mechanisms and kind of activities that I
found through covid because it was like
a lot of the stuff that I couldn't do
through covid then I became a runner and
I'm like well now I can't run because I
can barely like I can't breathe and when
you're on blood thinners for anybody
that doesn't know that's also a huge
risk because if you get cut or you fall
or you get bruised you hit your head
like you could potentially have internal
bleeding you could it's preventing your
blood from clotting so if you get cut
like you're not gonna plot and then you
can bleed out so it's like I have all of
these things in my mind I'm like what if
I go for a run am I able to drive in the
car like what if I get hit by some all
of these wild things so it was just like
an emotional roller coaster and you know
I watched a lot of TV and then there was
one point where I just kind of was like
all right you don't take this
opportunity because there's not many
times where like nobody's bothering me
to do work like I can actually watch TV
and I shouldn't feel guilty so I really
leaned into that watched a lot of TV and
you know took like that first week
before I even told anyone what happened
and then finally I told everybody like
the internet
and then you know everybody that I think
I've ever worked with like all of the
brands that I'd worked with like
everyone was sending me food and Flowers
and Gifts so I was like super just
grateful and overwhelmed by like all of
the support you know publicly privately
and just I don't know it kind of like
just made me feel really great to just
you know know that I have such an
incredible support system and again
Jenna my sister who may be watching
um just super grateful for her because
she was like literally there like 24 7 I
mean she was in the hospital I was like
you have to go home like you you can't
stay here I'm good I'm fine so yeah so
definitely very grateful for everyone
just such an emotional roller coaster
and as you know it's just like that that
recovery like you think you're okay and
then like it doesn't make sense I'm like
why can't I do what I just did like last
week yeah
uh Gene I have a question for you to
follow up on that but I'm going to pause
to say giveaway time one more time uh
well not one more time but again
um for the audience members shout out
your support system I want to know you
know who's taking care of you who helped
you out during your clot experience so
this is specifically for our caregivers
out there and our survivors to shout out
your caregivers who is in your support
system you know give them some love in
the chat
um so Gene as a follow-up how do you
engage your patients about their mental
health you know do you have any specific
resources that you like to share or
words of wisdom and comfort
um during this experience yeah no you
know this is part of the um I often see
people after they're diagnosed right so
they come to my outpatient clinic in in
you know the first visit in the first
month is the barrage of you know why me
and what does this mean and and you know
as both of you know oh my gosh I'm an
anticoagulation what can I do what
should I not do
um I I will put in a plug for Medic
Alert bracelets
um which thank you uh Ariel I mean it's
important and and they're not what they
used to be when I was growing up you
know those little metal linky bracelets
they're actually very sophisticated now
and and they they don't look like
medical bracelets but I think it's very
important for for you to carry something
with you letting people know and that
sort of segues into your support group
so often
um
I find that that patients want to talk
about it most patients and patients that
are are worried about things we've sort
of already touched on they're worried
that any symptom they have might be a
new blood clot and how do they figure
that out they worry
um you know if they go off
anticoagulation is it going to come back
and so I direct them towards resources
that are available in a lot of different
areas
um the world thrombosis day.org website
the stop the clot website natf there's a
lot of things out there but I think
talking with patients I show patients
their scans so I show them their
pulmonary embolus scans we go over their
ultrasound of their leg or their arm and
we talk about symptoms you know and what
is a recurrent symptom versus what is
something they shouldn't worry about I'm
fortunate enough to have
um a lot of providers that work with me
nurses pharmacists nurse practitioners
and so as part of our anticoagulation
Management Service we have a a hotline
basically where they can call somebody
and and ask about the symptoms that
they're having so I think it's very
important whether you have a large uh
support group like Justine might have or
you know one or two or three you know
close friends that know that that you
have a blood clot and have some anxiety
but very important to bring it up with
your physician because I know it can be
PTSD like for many patients in in going
through you know as you said Justine I I
know people who've had blood clots due
to air travel right and then some of
them are like oh my gosh am I going to
be safe on the plane and so we talk
through how to make them be safe on the
plane and decrease their risk for for
getting another clot and I think that's
key
um I will say that if you don't bring it
up with your provider they may not be
aware that you're having stress uh and
so although you can get a lot of support
from groups that are out there there are
some Facebook support groups
um they are there both of you are doing
a great job bringing awareness
um to blood clots and then there are the
support materials that I discussed but
um your provider can also help you just
have to let him or her know
yeah I think it's great too like a lot
of there's so much Telehealth now that
you know you have the ability to just I
can just text my doctor essentially and
then it was interesting because I had
made an appointment I have another I
don't know it's called one medical so
it's like a basically like a doctor
prescription kind of thing that I had
got like a few years ago when covet
happened because I was like I don't even
have a doctor so that was like my first
thought I'm like well how do I get one
and then also I'm super grateful that I
sprained my ankle and it hurt my knee
and I I was already like in the the
system for my uh provider so like when
all this happened I was already
thankfully in the system so like if you
guys don't have a doctor
you should proactively just find one
find something because when something
actually does happen like the whole
process to to sign up to make sure your
insurance is accepted because I ended up
going to one of the doctors that was
outside of my insurance so then I ended
up having to pay out of pocket for that
and those kinds of things can really
really add up so I think just finding
you know just something and especially
now because of covid the wait lists are
really long to sometimes get uh like a
primary care physician so even after
this happened it took me almost four
months to get another primary care
physician that was in my area so I think
just kind of having that set up was
super helpful
um so if that's if anybody doesn't have
a doctor or something now I think that's
something that that's your homework for
this week find yourself somewhere that
you can go in case of emergency yeah
maintain those relationships you know
again ICP I'm a hematologist so I see
somebody
um you know a little bit after the fact
in addition to their primary care doctor
and if your primary care doctor refers
you to a hematologist and you know keep
that appointment uh and maintain ties
with that most people will see you at
least once a year once every two years
and I think it is important to have a
long-term relationship like that because
it is a lot easier to text uh your
physician these days
um a total tangential thing we love
Telehealth and Medicine absolutely love
it it's great for patients we've seen in
the past it's great to discuss new
symptoms
um the public health emergency ends soon
and that may affect what happens to
Telehealth so
um you know use your platforms to to
advocate for for uh Telehealth as well
had to put that in there this is also a
question I had so there was there's a
blood test that you can do correct it's
like the D-dimer that you can test if
you're having or have had one like how
does that work yeah no I I think that
that's a great point to bring up and I'm
glad you brought that up because the in
most people there's people are in the
normal range for a D-dimer and what is
D-dimer D dimer is a measure of your
blood clotted and then your body's
breaking it down and D-dimer is fragment
of a an old blood clot that's been
dissolved by your body and so people who
have new blood clots have very high
levels uh for the most part and so I
often see patients and they go to an
emergency room and particularly if
they've had a blood clot in the past and
it's sometimes hard to tell on the
ultrasound of the leg or the CT scan of
the chest what's old and what's new a d
dimer can be so helpful and a lot of
places forget to to draw that in the
emergency room so I I'm glad you brought
that out because when we have patients
who call us and they they're worried
they're off anticoagulation now because
we you know like like you Ariel with
their first clot it might have been in
the setting of surgery and we usually
just treat people for three to six
months but if they in and we just had
this happen yesterday in my practice and
actually this morning
um somebody had leg pain right so the
first thing we do is get a d dimer and
if it's high then we go and get the
ultrasound of the leg or if they have
chest pain we go ahead and get the CT uh
PE CT scan so it's a great test yeah
yeah so I asked because like was that
something that my mom also told us is
like if you're gonna go get a blood test
like ask for the D-dimer because
sometimes they won't do that and then
even my sister because obviously we're
related and we think she may actually
have thoracic outlet syndrome also but
the nerve kind so she was having some
chest pains and um so she went in and
and got tested and they did the D-dimer
and they're like okay no you're okay so
maybe it's something else like you're
postcovid whatever so
um it was just great to know that like
that's something that you can go in and
ask for or just to make sure yeah and
and I think the asking is important
again advocating for yourself and your
health care because as I said a lot of
emergency room doctors
um I don't it may not be as aware of the
usefulness of the test uh or may
Overlook it uh and so it's important I I
think it's very very helpful
yeah I think also just
you can demand it but ask nicely and
then just keep asking and be like look
if something if something goes wrong and
you didn't do this test
like that's going to be on you be like
put it in my chart that you said that
I'm not going to do this or do that test
because you know I mean again like you
sometimes have to take the stuff into
your own hands and I mean these doctors
it's like also we can't blame them they
have tons of patience they're doing so
much stuff so it's like yeah they might
not be paying as much attention they
have a lot going on so I think just you
know keep on top of it but also just
remember like you know these doctors do
have your life in their hands so just
try to be as understanding as possible
and you know they'll reciprocate that
yeah but we are still a bit overworked
thanks to coven so
you know even before that I can't even
imagine I mean it's just going from
Patient to Patient like just even being
in the the emergency room because I was
in there for so long it's like the
amount of people because I was just off
in the corner just sitting on my blood
thinners just
nothing to do it's like I just saw so
many people just cycling in and out and
it was just kind of I don't know like
really kind of opened my eyes too of
like how much people see and how much
trauma they see daily that it's just
it's got to be incredibly overwhelming
and sort of at some point
they kind of detach I feel like from
that because you kind of have to yeah
and there's a mindset of in the
emergency room a very early on sort of
triaging and making a decision you know
and this person can go home this person
needs to be admitted this person we need
to figure things out a little more
um and and I do think that the you know
the D-dimer can actually help uh the
physicians in the emergency room or the
Urgent Care Center I've often seen you
know somebody go to their primary care
doctor in the primary care doctor gets a
d dimer and it comes back a few hours
later and then they Panic too right and
it's like oh my gosh you got to go to
the emergency room you might have a
blood clot so it's an important test
thank you both so we're in our last few
minutes and what I like to do at this
time is lightning round because we have
a lot of awesome questions from
um our viewers and so we're going to try
and get to as many as possible
um I will say before I do that that we
did have a
um a viewer share the winner of viewer
Sophia shared who her support system was
and it was her husband and her two
Amazing adult boys they are her primary
support system congrats Sophia you get a
T-shirt and thanks for sharing and shout
out to your support system
if anyone else has any tips for your
mental health or how you made it through
your Cloud experience feel free to put
them in the chat encourage one another
we love to hear those
um all right lightning round
you know shorter answers but still
the goodness of them
all right
um Justine
can you talk a little bit about any
anxiety you may have felt around being
on blood thinners and getting your
period how menstruation was for you
I mean I was just like what's gonna
happen like I was asking so many
questions I was even asking the um like
when I got out I was like can I get
BOTOX like what can I do like I was like
asking all these crazy questions like
can I get a facial can I shave my legs
what's gonna happen during my period and
for me like honestly everything was
normal the first couple of days I felt
kind of like a metallic taste which was
kind of weird but then I mean everything
was fine I had no issues I did feel like
I was bumping into things more just
because I was so cautious and the first
time I hit my head on like a cabinet I
was like
I gotta be I gotta be watched I'm on
watch but no I mean honestly everything
was fine and and I really had no issues
everything was was very very normal
all right some people will experience
heavier periods they've noticed them but
it definitely depends on the type of
medication you're on I think and how
your body responds but if it's getting
too heavy and out of control talk to
your medical provider and make sure
you're on the right
um anticoagulant all right uh Gene how
does a person's weight impact their
likelihood to get a PE slash I'll insert
can you just list some risk factors to
get a blood clot in general yeah no
weight actually is a risk factor and and
we look at body mass index uh and their
their calculators online that from
arrive different places where you can
calculate your body mass index a body
mass index over 30 has an increased risk
and over 35 and even higher risk about a
two and a half times to almost three
times greater risk of getting a blood
clot simply because of your weight uh
compared to somebody who who's in the
normal weight range so absolutely you
know I I've had patients lose weight
um because it decreases their risk for
getting a recurrence uh in order to come
off anticoagulation other risk factors
include having your leg in a cast uh
having a surgery particularly abdominal
pelvic surgery or joint surgery
having cancer being pregnant pregnancy
is a high risk for for getting clots uh
so there are a lot of and then there's
some other disorders that that
predispose
thank you
um this one's also for Eugene so
medication can be super expensive
without insurance do you have any tips
or recommendations for people who can't
afford their anticoagulants and what do
you tell your patients
yeah no this is a battle we fight every
single day
um and and it's with insurance companies
um that cover some drugs that don't
Medicare and Medicaid if you're enrolled
in those programs absolutely will cover
drugs
um we sometimes have to battle with them
to to cover the newer oral drugs that
don't need monitoring but Warfarin is
pretty inexpensive and it is covered by
Medicare and Medicaid so if you need
long-term anticoagulation even just for
a couple months there are ways to do
that there are also
um websites out there that will help you
find cheaper costs and health care
groups Health Care Providers Physicians
we have resources we have social workers
we have uh prior authorization processes
for people with insurance but we have
ways of getting drugs for for people
that need them you just have to let your
provider know and you really have to
have that relationship and let them know
and and we've seen you know some drugs
like if if you need Warfarin the Lovenox
that you need for the week to transition
over can sometimes cost thousands of
dollars so let people know
thanks for that
um Justine this one's for you and I'm
modifying the question a bit how have
you had to adjust your travel schedule
and then I'll put in parentheses
um anything you have to do to kind of
travel differently or prepare yourself
differently
um I mean I kept asking my doctor like
when can I travel and I really kind of
waited until maybe like two and a half
months so I didn't travel for a while so
I waited and I mean I'm kind of back to
a travel schedule now and I still have
I'm not on blood thinners but I do
always have them with me just in case I
am like I need to go back on them for
some reason
um and obviously I wear like compression
socks as well which are definitely
something that you can just get on the
internet and just Google compression
socks for flying so I did do a very long
long it was like a 34 hour travel day
and it was just like I could already
like
Not only was I super anxious I was like
okay I Gotta Wear My compression socks
I've got my medication just in case I
was making sure I was drinking a ton of
water and just trying to stay hydrated
and obviously I tried to to walk as much
as I can even you know when I'm on the
flight I'm like I'm gonna keep walking
up and down this aisle and until
somebody yells at me but pretty much
I've been going back to my travel I
haven't been doing as much of my
lightsaber training and I try to avoid
doing any kind of like overhead lifting
and being very careful about what I do
at the gym just because knowing what I
think caused it I'm trying not to do
that until I get the rib removed and go
through that recovery process
I love that I always share the same
travel tips I started
um having an aisle seat which is
something I never used to do I used to
be very much a window person but now I'm
all on the aisle because I'm up and down
walking walking walking I'm like I set a
timer on my watch because I just I'm
anxious my second clot did come after a
flight to your point Jean about like
that worry about flying again and so
walking walking compression socks can be
painful but
um yeah I don't know they're great
um
all right so last question and Justine
I'm throwing it to you what advice are
you giving to blood clot survivors out
there to anyone who's just interested in
hearing more about your story but what
advice are you giving I mean I think I
talked about it a little bit earlier
just knowing what your normal base rate
heart rate is your blood pressure and
those things because that's very very
important especially if you start
feeling kind of out of whack and I think
just advocating for yourself if you're
at the doctors
um and if you ever start feeling these
symptoms you know like the swelling or
like a weird pain you know you can kind
of
think it might be something else but the
fact that I mean the statistics of like
blood clot deaths is so high that it was
it was really scary for me to find out
because I didn't even realize that and
the fact that a blood clot can break off
go to your lungs can go to your heart
can go to your brain I think was what
was really scary for me and I think just
bringing more awareness to it if anybody
out there has these symptoms or if you
have friends or family members that are
also having these go somewhere go to the
ER go to an urgent care and get the help
that you need and just again advocate
for yourself you know your body better
than a lot of doctors do so if something
doesn't seem right you know if that
doctor doesn't listen you know go find
another one and just again know your
normal I think is is the most important
thing
awesome thank you so much Justine and so
much Gene for being here
um we are at the end of our session but
before we close out we would like to
thank you both and thank everyone for
celebrating World thrombosis stay with
us we were so honored to have our U.S
Patient Advocate
um with us and hope that you continue to
join us as we enter our 10th anniversary
next year
as we leave you today thank you for
sharing your journey with us today is
the global day for us to raise awareness
but we can't do it without you and your
stories and your support so thank you as
we continue to raise awareness for blood
clots together so we can reduce the
death and disabilities caused by this
condition as we leave you today we
kindly ask all of you on today's call to
download our social media image so that
you can drop drop it in the comments and
post it on your page in support of world
thrombosis day and don't think I forgot
about those gift cards we randomly
selected four people for giveaways
throughout the time so you will get
um your gift cards from Apple fifty
dollars and so
um check your DMs if you haven't already
and please visit
worldthrombosisday.org for more
information resources and to get
involved with the campaign if you
haven't already partner with us it's
free and easy thanks again everyone and
have a great day evening night good
night everyone bye-bye bye thank you
everyone for watching I see your
comments we appreciate you